leaked details of call of duty's future
ahead of the franchise's upcoming next
event plus uncertainty of overwatch 2's
battle pass mere weeks before its launch
all this on today's gamespot news
with more information about war zone 2
on the horizon as part of the upcoming
call of duty next some fans have
wondered what exactly will be happening
with the original version of warzone
reporter tom henderson on twitter claims
the game will be undergoing a name
change on november 28th and that quote
it looks like original warzone will
continue to receive updates and dlc it
seems the original warzone going forward
will focus primarily on the caldera map
set in the pacific which was introduced
as a part of what activision blizzard
called warzone pacific alongside call of
duty vanguard season 1 in november 2021.
like its predecessor war zone 2 will be
launching some time after the october
25th release of modern warfare 2 and
will feature many of that game's
mechanics vehicles and weapons having
warzone and war zone 2 coexist does line
up with what activision has said
previously about the two battle royales
namely that warzone will quote continue
on as a separate experience that will
include a continuation of player
progression and inventories within that
warzone experience that means skins
weapons and unlocks in the original war
zone will not carry over to war zone 2.
looking further into the future of call
of duty 2024's installment might tell a
story about the war in iraq twitter user
the ghost of hope who has accurately
reported on unannounced call of duty
details in the past said the campaign
for 2024's call of duty game will cover
what the us government calls operation
iraqi freedom and operation enduring
freedom as well as the battle of
mogadishu which took place years earlier
during the gulf war of the 90s the event
later adapted and dramatized in 2001's
black hawk down the ghost of hope said
it will be raven software developing the
campaign for call of duty 2024 raven
also developed the campaign for call of
duty black ops cold war if call of duty
2024 is indeed about the iraq war the
game will likely be contentious around
200 000 civilians died as a result of
the war and another game six days in
fallujah has generated a good amount of
debate and discussion for its themes and
elements one could only imagine that the
size and popularity of a franchise like
call of duty addressing those horrific
real-life events would result in an even
larger discourse looking toward a game
releasing much sooner fans aren't happy
about the revelation that new characters
will have to be unlocked through the
season pass in overwatch 2 as the sequel
moves to a free-to-play model while
blizzard has said the characters will be
available through the free rewards track
not requiring any extra payment critical
players have said that the system will
jeopardize overwatch's hero swapping
playstyle overwatch 2 releases on
october 4th and will completely replace
the original game on release which made
new characters available simultaneously
to all players through free updates fans
have taken to social media to voice
their concerns about this system
pointing out that it doesn't play nice
with overwatch's hero swapping gameplay
where players are meant to be able to
change to any character depending on how
the match is going players have even
unearthed interviews from the release of
the original overwatch that proved their
point with a reddit user posting an
excerpt from an ass technica interview
developer aaron keller now the game
director for overwatch 2. keller
explains that the original game was
released as pay once play forever
because quote it's so important to have
access to every hero in the game and in
the middle of the match to swap to any
hero they think is necessary he added
quotes sometimes you need a different
hero on your team like if you really
need a widowmaker right now you don't
want everybody saying i don't have a
widowmaker with unlockable heroes
already a part of the free track and not
directly involved in blizzard's
monetization for overwatch 2 it will be
interesting to see whether the studio
will choose to walk this decision back
in the face of fan backlash and that is
it for today's gamespot news what do you
think about warzone and war zone 2
somehow co-existing what do you think
about the decisions regarding overwatch
2's battle pass let us know in the
comments below and we'll see you next
week for more game spot news
you